let's jump to this next story and get
into uh you know just i guess some of
the goings on
and uh this story scares me this is the
kim potter trial manslaughter charge in
taser taser taser shooting just death of
dante right so the news today is they're
doing jury selection this story is
important because this is what happens
when you start losing your your core
moral framework so one of the things we
were just talking about is the
judeo-christian moral framework how
within it
i believe you know in the past there
were some you know a lot of bad ideas in
culture but a lot of good ideas
persisted a lot of bad ideas felt you
know were were uh no longer carried on
and that's that's that's good news we
have free speech we have life liberty
the pursuit of happiness we have
individual liberties we have the
innocent until proven guilty and a lot
of people don't know this but the the
concept of being innocent until proven
guilty is literally in the bible and the
formulation of this idea expanded
throughout history blackstone's
formulation is better that 10 guilty
persons escaped than one innocent person
suffer to benjamin franklin it is better
that a hundred guilty persons escaped
than one innocent person suffer
literally comes from the story of sodom
and gomorrah if there is but one
righteous person i will not destroy the
you know the city or you probably know
better than i do matt i bring this up as
we get into this story because as we
begin losing these values to a cult as i
like to call it i think i don't know
matt you refer to him basically the same
way uh they don't care about justice
they don't care about what's right they
just say we want retribution and we want
you to suffer so what happens in the
shooting of dante wright is a police
officer was trying to arrest a man on a
felony weapons charge he had a warrant
the dude breaks free and jumps into his
car she yells taser taser taser but
pulls out her gun shoots him he drives
off crashes dies from the gunshot wound
she would have been justified most i
think most legal experts say if
someone's wanted on a felony weapons
charge and flees and jumps in their
vehicle about to grab something then the
police are justified in assuming it's a
deadly threat but because she said taser
and because they said it was an accident
she's getting charged with manslaughter
like many of the trials we've seen so
far with written house with chauvin with
ahmed arbory all of these cases are
political
are not based in whether or not we're
going to try and find the facts it's
based on whether or not we can win in
the public space and the biggest
advantage the right has is that they're
not willing to commit harm against
others the left is the leftists will
burn down a city to get what they want
and that means these these people
running these trials these jurists uh
jurors the uh the businesses they're all
gonna say just give the left what they
want i gotta say if the cop was
justified in killing this guy deadly
weapons charged he dives into his car
assuming he's gonna grab a deadly war if
she yells out i love you before she
shoots him it's no different than
yelling out garble garble gun or taser
taser it doesn't matter what you yell
out when you're using justified deadly
force beforehand agreed yeah the other
thing to keep in mind and you almost you
already know this based on the track
record but one thing we know about blm
martyrs especially the ones from george
floyd and on
is that almost all of them are have a
history of really
horrific violent crime and almost always
against women so dante wright is no
exception there um i think it was it was
a felony weapons charge that he was
wanted on but that also stemmed from or
was related to
an armed robbery where he you know
allegedly
um put a gun to a woman and robbed her
and also committed sexual assault by the
way because he stuffed his hand into her
bra looking for the i guess for the
money and uh so sexual and choked her so
so
very similar to what george floyd did
you know barging into a woman's house
forcing his way into a woman's house at
gunpoint robbing her uh so dante wright
did that as well allegedly and um
and so we know that and and also the
other thing is i look at this as
from kim potter's perspective you know i
would i would equate it almost to like a
medical error or something that uh that
maybe would happen with a surge people
die from medical errors all the time
sometimes it's reckless and then you get
litigation but oftentimes it's just it's
a life-or-death situation surgeons are
human beings they're not perfect
it's not always going to go the right
way we just sort of understand that we
can't lock surgeons in jail every single
time a surgery doesn't go the right way
and uh so in this i look at it's kind of
a light she's she's thrust into this
life or death situation
that she didn't create dante wright
created it number one by being you know
a felon and wanted on a warrant and then
number two by fighting the cops so now
he has taken what what could which
should have just been a normal
interaction where he says okay i'm gonna
go with you i'm wanted on a warrant
that's it well and i'll go to jail
but he he turns it into this
life-or-death struggle he decided to do
that and then she makes a mistake in the
midst of that um and it's unfortunate
that she did but the idea that now we're
going to put you in jail for that
i think is uh is obsessed she knows
she she's heard on the body camera
footage saying i'm going to prison
and i think the reason she said that is
because of the political landscape
so my attitude
you know what really bugged me is when
all of these leftists came out and
started saying defund the police my
attitude was like cops you just quit
but none of them would do it
as bad as it had gotten now i understand
when activists go and say you know
abolish the police or whatever you
ignore it when they say abolish the
police and then start burning down
police departments and then kamala
harris fund raises for them and joe
biden wins an election after his staff
had been bailing these people out and 25
people die
you went to a point where you're kind of
like maybe you should give the people
what they want and a bunch of people on
the left got mad at me for saying it
because i was like abolish the police
okay and he's only saying that because
he thinks people will be upset after
they realize what happens when the
police are gone and i'm like maybe but
does it matter if i agree with you
so when i see kim potter and even she
seems to know the political
ramifications of what's happening today
and they still want to remain cops the
problem i have is that the people of
minneapolis the people in minnesota the
people in new york will not stand up for
the officers
and then the officers get thrown into
the bus they go to prison for these
things and i'm just like give if the
people of these towns are unwilling to
take responsibility for their own
communities maybe they should be given a
defunded police department to see what
happens maybe then they'll realize and
they'll change their vote wasn't this
officer i correct me if i'm wrong on
desk duty her entire career and because
of defunding efforts she was put on on
duty here
and what do you guys make of the
argument saying that she should have
never been there and that she should be
held responsible for making that
accident because it clearly does seem
like she was going after a taser but she
went after a firearm she didn't have
much experience in the field do you
think there should be some kind of
accountability for that or what's your
rebuttal against people talking about i
think if you look if if she's obviously
done on the force and so okay fine um so
there's accountability there but but i i
would stick by this
that he at dante wright as the wanted
criminal
and no they didn't arrest him i think
what was the original story they told us
that um he was arrested for like a an
air freshener or something some totally
bogus right bs it wasn't that at all he
was he was a wanted criminal and he was
there she was trying to arrest him he he
is the one who decided to escalate this
and turn it into a life or death he he
put his life on the line he decided to
do that that was his decision when you
start fighting and physically struggling
with a cop that's what's going to happen
that doesn't mean that the cop has every
right to just pull out a gun and shoot
you no matter what but um the moment
that you especially as a wanted felon on
a weapons charge the moment that you
decide to make that decision you have
now taken your life in your hands and i
don't think that we should put all that
onus on on kim potter no i agree and and
let's throw it to uh kyle rittenhouse
joseph rosenbaum threatened and then
decided to attack
a young man carrying a rifle
he created the danger kyle reynolds
didn't do it coward house fled from the
attack and tried to get away and then
the zebenski fired the gun i think when
we look at a lot of these stories the
the there's a big factor in whether or
not the individual was the person who
instigated or created the harm now of
course the left is now lying about first
they lied here he was pulled over for an
air freshener the cops it was unjust
because they need the cops to be the
ones who created the danger when in
reality we know this story is not the
case we know cal right now didn't create
the danger and then i'll throw it to the
ahmed arbory case ahmed arbory ran
towards the truck where the travis
mcmichael was armed with shotgun
flanked him around the truck and then
grabbed the shotgun from him
so whether or not you know i think there
if the question of the citizen's arrest
in that regard is that it was not legal
then yeah you can't stop someone while
armed it's false imprisonment it's a
felony and then if the person dies
that's felony murder but what we also
have to consider that ahmed arbury was
the one who tried grabbing the shotgun
for him creating that danger now in that
one it's a little more complicated
because you can argue the danger was
created by the mcmichaels for trying to
stop him that's why i think that one's a
little more murky and nuanced but
ultimately ultimately my point is i
think we typically say we side with
those who are being responsible and not
trying to create the danger but what
happens when the danger is resolved
and the person who didn't create it is
the one who's still alive we don't lock
them up in prison
yeah it's and it's made uh i talk to
cops all the time i'm sure you have
and uh i still i have the same question
i respect the hell out of police
officers who still decide to do this job
but they're in a position right now i i
can't imagine
doing this when you know that
the moment like you said kim potter said
i'm going to prison for this they know
that the moment
a criminal decides to turn things
physical
the police officer is in a no-win
situation no matter what happens after
this they lose possibly everything
either they could die and if they don't
die if they commit the sin of not dying
then um they could lose their whole life
and go to prison and that's it's a it's
a total
we can't have a functioning civilization
when our law enforcement officers are
put in positions like this this is why
i'm um almost entirely for abolishing
the police almost entirely because you
know part of me is like the police as uh
law enforcement makes sense we need in
my opinion good functioning law
enforcement i think uh many of our
anarchists and you know more and cap
friends might be like
but uh i do i think if you have a
functioning legal system you basically
have which is what is supposed to be a
neutral arbiter for conflict in in in
our pop our you know dense environments
that makes sense i don't want two
neighbors showing up and punching each
other in the face because they can't
resolve a dispute the cops get called
calm and they say we're the ones who are
going to handle this that makes sense to
me the problem i have now is that with
that you know proposition you've
mentioned the police know okay i pulled
this guy over
now he's giving me the business i'm out
i'm not going to stop him he's a violent
criminal i'm not on a gun charge for
armed robbery but i will not be kim
potter but what happens if you get
caught with with a weapon what happens
if you live in new jersey and like this
woman from pennsylvania she drove across
the bridge go to atlantic city didn't
realize she couldn't do this and had had
her legal gun with her in pennsylvania
you're allowed to have weapons she drove
across the bridge gets pulled over and
the cop gleefully said ma'am you are
going to prison for four years and tried
to actually destroy her life the problem
i have now is you do have these police
like kim potter saying i'm going to
prison because she knows the political
power of black lives matter but you had
these you had cops in minnesota traveled
south 20 miles to find a saliva i
believe was a solana owner who refused a
cafe owner she refused to close her
business during the covert restrictions
and the sheriff shows up with a smile on
his face and arrests her
if these cops are scared of black lives
matter to the point where they will let
them get away with riots and murder but
they're not scared to arrest regular
americans working-class citizens and
conservatives because these people never
do anything to resist thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you